thank you uh and welcome let me present
myself I am an open source engineer at
coiled and I've been working for the
last couple of years on performance
chiefly on dusk uh what is the ask the
desk is a fairly complicated uh
orchestration system that pushes through
several tens of gigabytes worth of data
on thousands of workers on the cloud
every in minutes
so
I want to ask this room how exactly do
you test changes when it comes to
Performance
when you have a customer that comes to
USA is your software is low
how do you you you change something to
make things better for your customer and
then you re you run a test and how do
you say yeah now my software is faster
what does faster mean for you
um
so before we talk about performance
specifically I would like to talk about
something that most people in this room
and in this conference should know from
the back of the hand when you how do you
do but functional testing so you have a
function you have some kind of
environment for it you have impulse on
the left outputs on the right and you
test that given the same inputs you get
this assert an expected output
this is box standard everybody does it
so how do most people do it well
somebody helping the pr on GitHub gitlab
whatever and as soon as that mfpr is
opened your CI kicks in and starts
spawning CI hosts and deploys everything
deploys the pr on multiple environments
multiple different configurations four
different versions of python three
different versions of your dependencies
Etc and reruns are very tall battery of
unit tests that
every single possible permutation of
your inputs is the output what to expect
yes green light no red light and only as
when you have a green light you can go
to the next step which is code review
and possibly merging to Main
what are the key key features that or
functional design that frequently we
don't think about because they are our
everyday life and we just give them for
granted
one is that
it runs at every change you don't get to
the end of a month-long spring without
having have a run the regression test
you run it for every single small PR or
this as small as possible so that you
can trace regressions to the change and
that those regressions don't even get
into your main
this is something we say yeah of course
but go back 15 years 20 years and it was
not like that you would have a giant
testing Sprint at the end of a giant
development Sprint and things were going
very badly typically
um another key feature of functional
regression testing is nobody needs to
remember to start it it just does it you
open the pr regression testing starts on
its own and you will get a red or green
light on its own
another thing is that it runs on CI
which is a standard environment you know
it's reproducible you can run it 100
times you will get the same results you
will not have the situation where the
developer says yeah run the test Suite
on my machine everything was green I
don't know why the client is complaining
and finally
the developer thinks yeah I change X Y
and Z and maybe possibly what w is also
impacted
CI does not care doesn't know CI re runs
everything from scratch and very
frequently it will find something that
the developer and the code reviewer
didn't think about that was also
impacted
so uh in his room who does this for
functional regression testing raise your
hand
who does okay
as expected most of the room
now
when it comes to Performance so not
testing what comes out but how fast
comes out who does it
one two three well more than I expected
actually
so performance regression testing is
painful frequently and also very
necessary
um what are the industry standard
solutions for it well one which some
people may know is airspeed velocity ASV
is it looks and feels like pie test you
write a function which instead of being
test underscore is time underscore
and you run some code it runs it a few
times and gives you mean and standard
deviation on how long it takes and then
it Compares it to a database of all the
runs to say hey this runs faster or
slower it's great but it's got
limitations
it's a micro benchmarking tool meaning
everything is great as long as what
you're testing is small it takes
microseconds or seconds it runs on a
single host
and the only thing you care about is
runtime but maybe performance for you is
not just runtime maybe it's also memory
usage
by throughput on your metered Cloud
connection and what and what not
and the other thing that is important
when you run on ASV is that you need to
trust that your performance will scale
linearly if you run those NPS SRA once
and it takes two microseconds
you need the confidence to say that when
you run it a million times
on a thousand different workers in
parallel
you are gonna have one microcycle
multiplied by 1 million divided by one
thousand which is a very very big
assumption which frequently is not true
so why is a tool like ESV uh not fit for
purpose for people like us at coiled
well what do we do a coil we develop
disk and we deploy tasks on the cloud on
Google and on AWS when we say deploy we
mean large numbers of workers at once
we can have 1000 workers that go up push
several hundreds of gigabytes worth of
data through and communicate with each
other producing a few terabytes worth of
network communication produce the
resulting shutdown
uh in these three lines example on the
very first line out after the import we
are starting uh cluster with 40 CPUs and
160 gigabytes of RAM
I could have literally added a zero
there and I would have had 400 CPUs in
exactly the same time
the second line we are connecting a coil
uh desk client to our cluster and then
we're doing stuff for example we are
reading a data set which I believe in
that case is 80 gigabytes and we're
saying okay in which specific area
around Manhattan take a specific area
about Manhattan that's New York City
taxes and give me the average trip time
and push button will have 80 gigabytes
worth of parquet data they gotta go
through into AWS are filtered and
processed and you can have however many
complicated calculations you want get
the result shut down and this is a
simple filtering and aggregation but you
could also have machine learning or
anything
what are the challenges here well first
of all
performance does not scale linearly
when you have
hundreds of gigabytes terabytes of data
hundreds tens thousands of ec2 instances
that need to communicate with each other
in peer-to-peer you do not see linear
scaling in performance if you have
something that is very performant on Two
Hosts you have no guarantee that's going
to be performant on 200.
for example what you may have hit
bottlenecks in the scheduler which is a
single host which is at the center of
the star configuration of the cluster
and the moment that has scheduler
reaches 100 CPU everything starts
slowing down and you will not reach that
until you start having hundreds of
workers
um and then you have the problem of
natural latency which is uh major and
again you can't really reproduce it on
localhost where everything is instant if
you run it on localhost you will have a
certain performance profile which is
completely different from when you run
on the cloud and it's completely
different from when you run
on a client's
corporate Network that maybe was not
updated for the last five years
so what do we do what did we do in at
coiled to say okay we want to make this
faster I I thought I made this faster
what do I do well no historically we
were retesting a single use Case by hand
so
customer complaint this use case is slow
okay I did a change
and run this change I start a cluster
once measure yeah it's 20 faster ship it
to the client
this was a very back practice first
because every time you needed to craft
your use case to measure
and that was out of repetition a lot of
mistakes
very frequently the developer would test
only the use case that they knew about
but actually when you start changing a
generic system like a scheduler
then you're not gonna be restricted to
only that one use case and we don't Fork
our software for fat or all different
class customers so you would have one
customer which is very happy because
their use case is faster and another
that the next week starts screaming
and finally there is variance when you
have many many uh many uh many many
workers that run on ec2 you don't have
you cannot expect precise timings like
if you're running three times you will
have plus minus five percent ten percent
twenty percent that entirely depends on
what you're doing
and very frequently developer only run
it once and got hey it's 20 faster great
except that if you're running five times
you get 20 faster 10 slower 20 is lower
and on the average you actually made it
slower
uh how did we solve this problem uh we
created a repo on GitHub which is called
benchmarks and on this repo we've wrote
a wealth of end-to-end tests these are
basic Pi tests that instead of running
on a single host on very small data like
you would be used to see on Pi test they
start full size coil clusters 10 20 100
workers and run
a whole array of use cases with as much
comprehensive as you would expect in a
functional regression test with
so you will have
thought product you will have data frame
joins we have machine learning training
I don't you don't you have the whole
thing we are adding to it and every time
a developer does a change for for
example speeding up data frame join
they will go through everything else as
well whether they want it or not and
they will get the result whether they
thought about there would be an impact
there or not
um in this repo we have two operating
modes nightly regression tests and a b
testing natural regression test is
exactly what the name implies
um with that git tip we rerun nightly
the whole thing over and over again and
every morning we have a new report that
shows the last several months worth of
runs
for all of our tests and show if there
is any change also since we don't really
want to have somebody whose job is just
to open this report and look through it
we have automated systems that spot
automatically
regressions in performance say at least
10 percent slower than the last week
there is automatically a GitHub issues
opened for us look at in this example
for example we have a shuffle operation
on a data frame
and you can see that performance is
pretty much consistent over time at some
point in October 2022 it became 5 10 20
10 20 faster
and then it was nothing to report about
for several months until one faded day
on March the 5th where somebody did
something uncouth and they deployed a
patch into Mainline which made it five
times lower
we got a GitHub issue the developer got
was noticed with kid blame and fixed the
problem and you see that the problem was
resolved
the other thing that we do is a b
testing we push manually into the repo
two corner to condo environments one
with our Baseline which is what we know
and love and the other with something
much more experimental like
uh some PR that has not been merged yet
CI will dig it in and run the whole
thing again not just once but five seven
ten times however many you want
and run and run and run and do
statistical analysis on that
and you can configure on the Fly the
size of our clusters
nightly regression tests we just do 10
workers because that costs money and it
runs a lot but sometimes for problems
that only appear when you have 200
workers we just tweak the number there
in in a config file and we run
everything and all the tests
automatically scale up in size so that
they thoroughly occupy a very large
cluster which is
representative of what you will actually
uh pay us for
example this is the output of a sprinter
they did recently then I was tasked for
make spilling faster or to fill into
this cluster and
at the end of my work I run a b tests
and I was convinced that spilling would
become faster and what I got was that
spilling became actually 80 slower
and some completing related tests that I
didn't even know about I didn't even
know would make this Kyle became 50 fast
and I was like oh well that's
interesting back to the drawing board
and that PR did not get much
and this is the thing
back in the day when we were doing
manual testing that PR would have just
gone into Main and the next week
somebody who heavily relies on this guy
off because it doesn't have enough
memory will start complaining because we
would not notice
um
we also do something that is called null
hypothesis analysis which is tests have
noise some tests are substantially more
noisier than either than others
so we run uh the Baseline twice in two
sets five times on its own and then five
times again without changing anything
and compare them pretend that there was
a change and the idea is that that
report must not show you anything if it
does that's noise and if you see a
change on the same test on the actual
actually B test you know you really
shouldn't be paying attention to it for
example here we see a cutout where we
have a test called testing of future
which is say hey in this A B test where
you change absolutely nothing we have
plus minus 30 depending on how you run
it and that means that test is no good
other tests say you have plus minus
maximum five percent so that's reliable
if in those tests I can see suddenly a
thirty percent on the actually be you
know you can rely on it
after you see this is very high level
summary of the whole test Suite you can
start drilling down in individual tests
here for example we have a view for Just
Two tests
um at the top we have one that actually
changed and we see a mean median and
standard deviation the median is the
blue bar the mean is the Crosshair and
the standard deviation is the horizontal
extent of the black line
and you can see on the top we have
something that was actually much faster
in my experimental branch
and with very little noise and at the
bottom we see a very noisy test which
maybe is faster in my by Branch but
actually it didn't signal to noise ratio
is so bad that I really shouldn't look
at it and this is exactly
this one that I was showing before and
at the top is exactly the one the blue
line
that I was showing before which was
already solid blue I already knew but
this tells me something more
and finally
if I still don't know so this is showing
me every one of those bars is 5 to 10
tests five to test test runs
if I want to see what actually happened
in every one of them
I can open our grafana this is something
that is available to all of our coil
class customers and I can see okay there
were this many tasks at this point they
were using this much RAM and at this
point it started spooling to disk so it
starts being slower or we were doing a
lot of network IL Etc we can
eviscerate it as much as we want to go
down and down and down into detail until
we understand exactly the small details
of what changed
so
what are we going from here first of all
we need to polish it we this is
something that is amazing for internal
use it's not quite yet something we
would like to get offered to customers
because it's a bit hacky at the moment
we want to make it smoother cleaner
polish it up and we would also like to
use expose more metrics to it at the
moment we have end-to-end runtime pick
memory usage every average memory usage
they are super useful but I have
questions like
how much more networked IO did I do how
much time did I spend on good CPU
seconds and how much did I waste on uh
Gill contention all these sort of
questions we have answers to those we
just need to expose them to the system
then we could also make it more
interactive just have um
you can click on okay I want this this
and this metric and have a portal that
gives you the answer on the Fly and
finally eventually we will have
something where a called custom customer
says or goes on the dashboard and says
okay I have this this and this run on my
a set this this and this run on my b set
give me some performance insights about
how these two sets of runs are different
any questions that people may have
[Applause]
well first thank you for your great talk
we have one question until now but I
think you can write your questions on
slido
what kind of visual visualization are
you using for the testing timings
uh so
these graphs I use Altair which it
generates static HTML files which we can
get conduct published on GitHub Pages
this is very crude not really practical
but it was something that was very hacky
and quick it's not going to last in the
long term we as I said we are going for
something more Dynamic and interactive
that we want to be able to click through
on the fly on a portal and have data
that is distracted on the Fly
uh this this one instead is grafana
which extracts data on the fly from
Prometheus and it's much more powerful
much nicer it offers a bit less
visibility in terms of
crazy aggregations that you want to do
in for example to generate these graphs
I needed to write some bootstrap
analysis which grafana doesn't do on
Autoville of the box but we can
make things
smoother there questioned by Mr B does
your system also Benchmark memory yes it
does
yes it does I don't have screenshots for
that but
um at the moment we have again three
measures end-to-end runtime average
memory usage across the cluster big
memory usage and we could add more again
we have for example we have the
information of manage versus unmanaged
memory whereas managed is what dusk
knows about
users tasks unmanaged memory is
everything else that we have no idea
Heap leaks
Etc we can break that down we can expose
it to this kind of metrics and analyze
oh hey in this PR you had a 30 increase
in unmanaged memory why I don't know
maybe because your hip is larger because
your chunk size has become larger
how do you distinguish performance tests
already conclusive on single machines
from the ones where you really need to
spin up a huge cluster
the short answer is none that you run on
a single machine is conclusive
it as I said when you run on local
cluster your performance profile is so
completely different from when you run
on a huge uh easy to Cluster where you
have
hundreds of or thousands of gigabytes
worth of ram hundreds of CPUs and
network latency through and through it
local cluster yes good start but then
don't assume that your thing is doing
what it does until you see numbers on on
the cloud or wherever else your
production is going to run
isn't testing at this scale extremely
costly
actually no
um our overnight tests are at the moment
are about 100 a pop with obviously two
time so it's not terrible and whenever
we need to do something serious like a
500 a thousand workers that of course
costs substantially more but it does so
doesn't happen every day and it's
typically money very well spent
is it possible to add p-values to the A
or B tests uh I read it there
we already used P values that's what you
have the
yeah you can read it on the overlay
is the plan to open source this project
project eventually
uh well actually the project is already
there it's just you need the whole
account to run it which will cost you
money
um
uh that said if you are a heavy Das
contributor we probably be happy to have
a chat with you and just give you some
coil clad call time for free if you're
developing tasks why not we are already
talking about that with Nvidia as a
matter of fact
would it be possible to simulate or
emulate Network performance on a single
machine instead of actually running in a
cluster yes theoretically practically
it's a big kind of worms and that
depends on how much you need to do it
and how much time you need to develop
such a thing which
you will never quite know if you did
quite right but yes it is possible just
not something to say oh yeah I can
totally simulate this yes you can but
careful
okay the next the last question I have
is is the cool GitHub stuff you showed
in a public repository you can look at
yes it's yes it's public
called benchmarks
okay then thank you again for your talk
and have a nice day
[Applause]